una nube de humo y aire lleno de gases
lacrimógenos frente a la residencia del
ex Primer Ministro implacano Los
Seguidores del funcionario acamparon
frente a su residencia en la jor y se
enfrentaron a la policía
Esto está sucediendo desde el martes por
la tarde la policía está aquí usando gas
lacrimógeno una y otra vez llegó aquí
desde anoche y estaré aquí uno dos o
tantos días más por él si es necesario
me resulta muy difícil hablar debido al
gas lacrimógeno
el martes las fuerzas policiales
intentaron sin éxito detener a can
alegando que el ex Primer Ministro no
había comparecido ante el tribunal
acusado de corrupción tras el intento de
detención estallaron protestas en las
principales ciudades de Pakistán e
incluso ante su embajada en Londres en
Twitter Khan afirmó que la maniobra de
las autoridades era para secuestrarlo y
asesinarlo y que las fuerzas policiales
estaban utilizando munición real algo
que niegan el martes por la noche can
prometió que se presentaría en el juicio
por el 18 de marzo pero la policía
rechazó la oferta
dio garantías de que comparecería ante
el tribunal el 18 de marzo Así que ahora
no tienen motivos para detenerme
el exjugador de Cricket convertido en
político ha evitado aparecer en público
desde que recibió disparos en un
atentado el pasado noviembre en un mitin
en el que pedía el adelanto de las
elecciones
destituido de su cargo hace casi un año
tras una moción de censura kana afirma
que el intento de detención y la
destitución política son un complot del
gobierno de su sucesor shabat sharif
para asegurarse de que no pueda
participar en las próximas elecciones